[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of coordinated terrorist
attacks struck Paris this morning at 9
13 a.m targeting landmarks across the
city the bombings hit the Louvre the
Champs Elise the center pompadou and the
Arc de Triomphe oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
hi Mom hi Mom oh my God
yeah honey
I'm okay watch what happened where have
you been
I'm fine I'm okay I'm okay
yeah no I'm I'm not actually
um it's a long story but I'm like what
are you able to leave no no no no no I'm
I'm not
Grandma knows foreign
[Music]
yeah I I'm fine I gotta go okay
oh neither agents
official statement at this hour so far
no terrorist organization has claimed
responsibility for the attacks however
multiple Witnesses have reported seeing
this suspicious individual although
officials have not identified a suspect
at this hour
foreign
really hope you're okay
I'm okay and safe period I don't have
reliable service yet but please know I
am all right exclamation mark devastated
for those who are not broken heart emoji
foreign
[Music]